Hey, Matt?
>> What's up?
>> So I've been looking through this genome,
and I'm looking for a single gene that
affects some of the complex traits. Like, I
don't know, depression, or intelligence, maybe even schizophrenia.
>> Well Lauren, although we learned in the last lesson that there are
traits that can be influenced or
even completely controlled by changes in indvidual
genes. Most traits don't work like that and in fact I think it's
time that we turned out focus to
understanding the genetic basis for complex traits.
While some traits, like the ones we talked about
in the last lesson, can be explained by the alteration
of a single gene, most traits are actually complex. You
have over 20,000 genes in your genome and they're all
working together. Your environment matters, too. What you eat, where
you live, your daily activities. And most of the traits
that you mentioned, Lauren, are actually complex and influenced by
both genetic and environmental factors. So for us to understand
how both these sides contribute to a trait, we'll have
to come up with some unique tools. We're going to jump
right in in just a second with the trait that
affects people all over the world. Risk for breast cancer.
>> Also, don't forget about your concept map. I want you
to print this out and fill out the blanks as we
go along. And as always, you'll have a chance to see
what you learned from this at the end of the lesson.